BRUNO AZIZA: Hi, everyone.
This is Bruno Aziza,
and I'm here with Shan,
and he is the brain behind
the anomaly detection design
pattern that we are
launching this week.
If you saw our earlier
videos, these design patterns
are designed to
help you get started
and develop a solution to a
business problem you have.
So Shan, thank you so much for
taking the time with us today.
Tell us, first of all,
what is anomaly detection
and why does it matter?
SHAN KULANDAIVEL: Thanks
for having me, Bruno.
I appreciate it.
First, I need to let
you know that I've
had three cups of
coffee today in the hope
that I can show up here with
at least half as much energy
as you do, but I don't
think it's going to cut it.
I need to figure what
you have for breakfast
and have that for breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
But anyway, with
that, let's talk
about anomaly detection, right?
Let me ask you this question.
Let's assume this is
a regular working day
and you have to drive
in to work, right?
You probably saw hundreds and
hundreds of cars on the road.
What are the one or two cars
that you're going to remember?
BRUNO AZIZA: Yeah, that's true.
I mean, my commute was actually
pretty easy this morning.
But you're right, if I
drive to work, I don't know.
I'll probably remember
a couple of cars.
Maybe I saw three red cars?
But apart from that--
SHAN KULANDAIVEL: Yeah, maybe--
BRUNO AZIZA: --I don't know.
SHAN KULANDAIVEL: --one with
a flashy paint or maybe one
that was outsized, right?
The small, on the smaller
side, or a large car, right?
Let me give you
another scenario.
I've got an 18-month
toddler at home.
She's a bundle of energy, always
running around doing things,
asking for things.
And she's around us, right?
So she stays in the
background, and then we
go on with our life.
But the minute that
she's out of sight
and we don't hear
anything from her,
that's when we know she's
up to something, right?
She's probably getting ready to
test out whether electrocution
is fake news or not.
Like, she's probably
grabbing something,
trying to insert it
into the power socket.
Now, what is common between
these two scenarios?
It is the fact that you've got
a constant stream of data coming
at you, but the data
that is outlier,
or that is unlike the
others, is the one
that is more [INAUDIBLE].
It gives you
valuable perspective,
tells you something
new, and, in my case,
potentially helps
me avoid danger.
Now, that's basically what
anomaly detection is, right?
Now, beyond those simple,
straightforward examples,
there's a lot of applications
for our customers.
Let me give you a few examples.
Let's say you're an
e-commerce provider.
Monitoring your
transaction data,
monitoring your card data,
monitoring your [? auto ?]
information, your
monetary information,
real-time [INAUDIBLE],,
you're going
to be able to detect
fraud much better
and prevent fraudulent
activities before it's
too late.
Here is another example.
Let's say you're a
manufacturing company, right?
You've got hundreds and
hundreds of equipment
in your factory floor.
Now being able to
analyze sensor data that
is coming from those
equipments in real time
and being able to detect
anomalous patterns
means you're able to schedule
proactive maintenance for maybe
equipment that
needs maintenance.
Or you can pull out equipment
from your factory floor
before it's too late.
Always, you are
going to be able to--
you're going to be dealing
with expensive repairs.
Or even, in some
cases, you'll have
to shut down your
entire factory floor,
leading to significant costs.
BRUNO AZIZA: We talked
about e-commerce here.
We talked about manufacturing.
But, of course,
anomaly detection
is appropriate in
financial services,
in telecommunications.
So many of the folks
listening to us
will be able to apply that
for their business, really,
regardless what industry.
So you wrote a
great detailed blog
on the techniques being
used and how people
can take advantage of it.
Take us through some of them.
SHAN KULANDAIVEL:
We've published three
different patents as of today.
So the first one, we worked with
the telecommunications customer
to build a network log-based
anomaly detection--
our intrusion detection system.
So this customer had a
rule-based system in place,
right?
So rule-based
systems are when you
know of a specific pattern or
a [INAUDIBLE] or an intrusion,
and then you codified
that and used this, right?
That works great, but
the significant drawback
of that is it can only
detect known packets, right?
Now, we all know the dynamic
world that we live in, right?
There are new forms of internet
code attacks every day.
It's a constantly
evolving landscape.
And so we work with the customer
to implement AI technique
called [INAUDIBLE] clustering.
It's basically unsupervised
[? knowledge ?] technique
to implement in our
network detection system
based on their NetFlow logs.
Let me give you another example.
So we work with a customer who
is basically a SAAS platform.
Their additional trust and
safety platform basically
provides anomaly detection as
a service for their customers,
who are mostly in
financial services,
and e-commerce, and
digital commerce leaders.
So we-- that customer was
able to [? liberate ?] some
of the patterns that we
publish to basically get up
and running, roll out
a production system.
And in fact, they were
able to basically go
to market and scale and
meet the needs of some
of their very large customers.
And their customers are
some of the biggest names
that you would think of when you
think about digital commerce.
So what we are
seeing is customers
are now able to start, not
necessarily from the ground
floor--
they've already got the
scaffolding in place.
They've got a system
that is architected
based on best practices.
They're able to bring their
knowledge of their business,
their domain, and really
finetune the system so
that they are able
to better serve
the needs of their customers.
At the end, that's what we want
customers to be able to do,
right?
It doesn't make sense
for every single customer
to cobble together a system,
spend a lot of energy building
out a system.
They should really
be focused on how
do they bring their knowledge
of their business, things that
are unique to the business,
and apply that to the patterns
that we provide so that they
are able to see value really,
really quickly.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's right.
Well, Shan, thank you so much
for taking the time with us
today.
There is a blog
that's coming at you
with the reference to all these
techniques and these customer
examples.
And like Shan just
explained, the goal
here is to take best practices
we've learned from customers
and then give you the
working code, the samples,
the technical guidance
so you can apply this
at your own company
and accelerate
your [? pass ?] to value.
Shan, thank you so much
for the time, again.
The links are down here.
We want to know what you
think about these patterns,
and we also want to know
if there are patterns
you want us to develop.
Don't be shy, put
them in comments,
and we'll talk to you very soon.
SHAN KULANDAIVEL: Fantastic.
Thanks, Bruno.